foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five as we talk
about your life and your money before we
go to the phones a couple of updates uh
right quickly
um
irony of ironies uh Zoom has announced
that their employees must come back to
work in the building
if that doesn't strike you as funny I
don't know what does okay
I'm just saying and of course I've
caught so much hell because I have said
Ramsey we work from work at Ramsey
that's where we work from we don't work
from home we work from work and well
you're not flexible no I understand that
humans need to be around humans and that
productivity and creativity and vision
go up when humans are in direct contact
with other humans it's uh it's a basic
tenet of humanity a human being not just
a human doing and uh so we work from
work at Ramsey all of us are in this
building together and that's why we get
so stinking much work done and while
we're so smart and pretty and all the
things that we are so there you go so
you're telling me that Zoom employees
don't zoom in to their yeah
now they gotta zoom out to work yeah
zoomed out now they're now they're now
they're going to zoom into the office
I just think it's I think it's funny I'm
sorry
um it's just because I think probably
because I caught so much hell about it
yeah so you know but the other thing on
a more serious note uh John deloney and
I took a call from a young uh Widow last
week in her 30s her husband had died in
a construction accident and she was uh
her home was in foreclosure and she was
in tears through the whole call and it
has tugged at the heartstrings of
everyone who's listened to that call
John and me included and um
uh I had if you have heard that or yet
to hear it but you'll hear that I
explained to her she's not going to lose
the house and that we're going to get uh
Lisa our senior uh financial counselor
that works with crisis stuff on on the
job here and furnish it to her take care
of her because as uh people of the
Christian faith were instructed by our
book to take care of widows and orphans
and so we do that's simple and so we
took care of her uh Lisa's met with her
she's got all kinds you know the chaos
that was all over her life is starting
to come into order the house well of
course not be foreclosed on she had a
sixty thousand dollar mortgage on 375
000 house we're not losing that house
boys and girls okay so uh not happening
so anyway we didn't lose the house
everything's gonna be fine there's a lot
of details to be buttoned up but just an
update that uh she's fine she's fine and
literally thousands of you have reached
out to us to offer assistance to her
Finance and so forth on the different
social media platforms thank you for
that number one we have no way of
organizing all of that stuff we don't
run a Telethon and so there's no
possible logistical way we could number
two she doesn't need it she's under
control we got we got her yeah you know
a couple people stepped up in the
community uh the church you know hooking
her up with the church that's going to
help her we've got Lisa who's got
superpowers when it comes to negotiating
with foreclosures and dealing with
mortgage companies and she has all of
the regulatory knowledge that strikes
fear Into the Heart of collectors and so
all of that so we got we got it we got
it she's in good shape thank you guys
but let me just tell you the thing I
wanted to bring up was thank you a for
all of you that reached out and those of
you that even thought gosh I wish I
could help her yeah you know here's what
we've always done in 30 years of doing
the show because sometimes one of these
things elicits this kind of a response
from our wonderful audience because we
got great people in our life absolutely
is hey what that means is God is telling
you to help
not her but somebody else there's plenty
of folk right there within reach of you
whoever you are that need help there's
plenty of folk that two thousand dollars
will change their life okay a thousand
dollar car for a single mom in that
situation change your life yeah and
ten thousand dollars to do it for ten of
them so this is why you get out of debt
this is why you live like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else so what I'm asking you to do in
this particular case is take the
function take the uh the spiritual
Direction you feel inside of you to help
and go help yeah you're not gonna help
this particular lady but there's one
just like her down the block I promise
you they're all over the world and so uh
help that's the word that's what it's
for because here's the thing if we the
people take care of we the people we can
make the government as irrelevant as it
actually is
you can put them out of business I know
that drop that put them out the helping
people business that would
um alleviate a lot of Heartache a lot of
pain a lot of taxes yeah it would
alleviate a lot of stupidity and it
would take the power from politicians to
buy your vote that's a good word so we
the people taking care of We the People
is how it's supposed to be done it's
called Community it's called connection
and uh it's called generosity it's a
good muscle for everyone to flex every
so often and um inviting you guys to do
just that and again thank you for your
response to that lady that was a
heart-wrenching call and situation it
really was and hopefully for the
listeners it shows you know we talk all
the time Dave this is a community we're
not just people telling you get out of
debt get there are Facebook communities
there are people doing this with you and
they truly care about your journey
they're right there with you and if that
doesn't show it I don't know what it
does 500
000 people on the baby steps Facebook
page yeah I mean the baby Facebook
Community yeah you want to get some
advice they will tear you up in there
they will tear wheel Terry but they
don't think I'm tough
jump your butt
nerdy
but I mean yeah there's
eight there's a lot of interaction going
on amongst uh you guys our tribe us uh
this is not simply us barking at you on
one end of a microphone and you on the
speaker and on the other side there's a
lot going on here and this kind of a
thing illustrates that it does it does
there's there's people out there rooting
for you they've been there they know how
it feels and the chance that they get to
jump in and help they're going to take
that chance well that's how you ended up
you know you and Sam end up becoming
Financial Peace University coordinators
heck yeah you don't go through this and
not want to help somebody on the other
side of it because it changes your lens
now when you walk out you notice the
person behind you in the checkout you
know what I'm saying you notice you
start to notice things that you've never
noticed before and you know you see that
person taking out their phone and
checking their account before they pay
you see that stuff now and so yeah you
got to go back and help pay it forward
once you're aware you can't be unaware
that's right you know it does open up
your eyes and get things moving so guys
jump in and do that just find somebody
to be a blessing to uh the odd thing is
is that it'll bless you the odd thing is
is that generosity actually does as much
or more for the giver than it does the
receiver and it seems like Jesus talked
about that so there you go uh the The
Giver is more blessed you know is what
it amounts to and so it's good it's a
good it's a good exercise it's a good
reminder for all of us that this is
where help comes from
God does not use governments God uses
people to help people and such it's his
preferred tool so keep that in mind next
time someone wants to announce a new
program
this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw or Ramsay personality is my
co-host today last week we put Dr John
deloney's new book on pre-sale it comes
out October the 3rd building a
non-anxious life the six daily choices
that you can make
to eliminate the things that cause
anxiety anxiety is a symptom not a
problem according to Dr John he's
exactly right so uh yeah when if you
want to not have the fire alarm go off
uh don't take the batteries out put out
the fire
that's the idea and so let's do a little
preventive stuff here building a
non-anxious life does that sound good to
have a little more peace in your life
you have Dr John can show you really how
to do it and uh this book is on
pre-order it's twenty dollars and we're
going to throw in 75 worth of free bonus
items including the ebook the audiobook
and one of John's talks uh all of that
uh for one price because if you pre-buy
it it helps us with the marketing and a
bunch of you had thousands and thousands
of you purchased it in the last five
days thank you thank you thank you for
that we appreciate the response it's
been explosive and um so building a
non-anxious Life by Dr John deloney
sounds good it is good let's all try
that together I love the book it's
absolutely yes all right Chris all right
let's do this Krista is with us in
Little Rock hi Krista welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hello thank you for having me my
pleasure how can we help
um my husband and I want to build a
house
um we are currently we have three kids
we're in about a thousand square feet
um one tiny little bathroom and our
oldest is a girl and she's about to be
12.
it's fabulous it's the joy of My Life
um they can't stand it any more than we
can anymore Suddenly Last year it felt
extremely small I guess because all my
kids are growing up
um so we want to build my aunt as a
realtor and so we got um a market value
on our house and we could probably
pay off the debt pay off the mortgage
and walk away with like 40 cash
um
the problem is we're both self-employed
which is recent I was a homemaker before
and worked kind of sporadically and then
now it's becoming a more of a full-time
position but he quit his job in October
and is doing construction work
independently now our income is going
way up but it's
both self-employment so yeah you're
gonna have to have two you're gonna have
to have two years of tax returns that's
right
right and our income was like
um 65 last year
um with all of our side hustles and
everything that I think that was like
adjusted gross
um so it comes really well the oldest
one's 12 what are the other two but 12.
um the her little brother nine and four
okay that's how old our nights were when
we sold our house
okay we paid off the IRS it was the last
remaining debt from our bankruptcy
because the IRS is not bankruptible if
you didn't hear there forever
um and so I got rid of the last debt and
um moved to a different school system
was our motivation our motivation wasn't
to build uh but we cleared up everything
and had uh a little bit of money like
you're talking about 30 or 40 Grand or
something it wasn't enough to get a
house and
um we rented for two years
we considered that
um right now our mortgage is only 455 a
month that's what the escrow and
everything it's up to you where do you
want to live you can't build I was going
to say you don't really have much of a
choice
you want to live in a little house or
you want to live in a rental house
you can't build
you don't have two years of tax returns
like with enough income well if you know
if you if you can do it on the income
that you're showing you have two full
tax rate years of tax returns already I
thought you kept telling me how recent
these self-employment is
yeah the self-employment is recent yes
or for him you have to have two years of
tax returns they're not going to count
his income okay
of self-employed tax returns because
when you open a business the mortgage
company doesn't think you can pay it
unless you've done it for two years
right
that's true I mean I
I've been right where you you're at
Krista you know Sam and I we had our own
business and you have to be able to show
the stability of that especially you
know just starting out like you guys
just starting these businesses and even
for your own self I would think that I
would want to know okay we do we're
doing this thing it's stable so even I
would want the Peace of Mind of having
those two years
um for myself not just for the
documentation purposes we did not move
we moved kids exactly the same age as
yours but we are a little bit younger
than yours a little bit
um but
um but we did not move because of house
size we moved because of school district
and because we could clear the debt in
the one Fell Swoop and so again and then
we rented for two years so we could save
up and buy a house of course in our case
we did it with cash but the
um
that that would be what I would do and
the reason I know that's what I did so
uh if you don't then you're staying in
that house for two years which I think
they should because For the Money Krista
I mean you guys still have some money to
save up for a down payment and you're
going to do that a lot faster with the
mortgage payment you have as opposed to
an inflated rate rent payment I'm I'm
stressed already with three kids in one
bathroom but um I get it I mean I hear
you so either one's fine with me you're
all's choice but you know the the third
choice is to get some kind of rip-off
subprom mortgage and get yourself
screwed over don't do that that's not it
that's desperation and you're not
desperate you're just motivated
and and what I'm trying to say is I
think your need is a reasonable need I
don't think you're being a drama queen
okay but I'm also telling you you've got
these boundaries that aren't gonna these
guard rails that aren't going to let you
get off the interstate where you want
well I just didn't want you
want to have oh you're you're going to
they're you know they're not going to
give you the loan
okay
you're not going to get a construction
loan and you're not because you're not
going to get a permanent takeout the
permanent takeout is the approval for
the mortgage the permanent mortgage that
takes out the construction loan and you
can't get approval for that without two
years of tax returns of self-employed
income
right okay okay and can I ask a
secondary question
I have an offer from my employer client
it's rolling over to employer he's
currently building a pretty massive
River Resort in our area
um that's why my employment has gone way
up um from just a couple hundred dollars
a month to three or four thousand a
month and he is offered as a health
appearance to the bank to roll me over
onto partial salary plus commission for
each rental is that an offer that I
should take or what should I consider
when thinking of taking that as an
option
okay
how you don't need to do it to get the
house because your husband's income just
started in October so we've got a
two-year burn from there
by then your commission will also be
stabilized and you'll know you'll have a
you'll have two years of tax returns so
you're not the problem uh on getting
approval both of you are the problem
okay so moving to this doesn't solve the
problem short term for getting the house
right so the only reason you move to it
is if it's a better deal financially
which way you make the most money
well it's hard to know because it's a
vacation rental so we don't know how
busy we would be so I don't want to look
back and say oh I I ripped him off
because I got way more salary than I
should have and I don't want to look
back and say wow I could have made so
much more employers don't get ripped off
long term they fire you
right it's a comp plan doesn't work we
change the comp plan or we let you go so
he's not going to get ripped off long
term he might get ripped off for one
year but after that he's going to go ah
Krista we're gonna fix this yeah yeah so
uh that's what we would do too I mean
it's reasonable so uh
you know I I think the trick is just
what which way do you make the most
money because the only stability is in
the actual income it is not in the
structure
the money is what gives you stability
not the method that the money comes to
you
so this idea I have a steady job is a
laughable that's true you know because
there's nothing steady but your ability
to go kill something to drag it home no
that's right come on Dave I mean that
that you yeah you go make it happen
you're the secret sauce so I would just
sit down and whatever combination it
sounds like the guy's really flexible
and a good employer and he's wanting to
you know he's got a he's got a rock star
in you so he wants to motivate you so
figure out the way that helps him the
most and helps you the most I think
you'll have a win-win this is the Ramsey
Show
thank you
foreign
[Music]
home buying Market but there's a way you
can get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're glad you're here Lane is
next in Louisiana Eileen how can we help
hey how are y'all better than we deserve
sir how can we help
man um my my situation I don't think is
near as bad as a lot of the ones that
you guys come across
um
I'm going to start investing in real
estate but the problem that I'm having
right now is having the extra money
um that I can set to the side in order
to start investing in real estate right
and uh I just wanted some ideas on how I
can start you know tackling the debt
that I have to be able to free up some
of my income in order to start investing
it
yeah I think that I think that you have
the right idea knowing that you got to
get out of debt first before you would
even think about buying real estate and
it sounds like this is for wealth
building purposes Beyond just being a
personal residence right
yes okay are you do you live in a house
now that you purchased
yes I do okay all right can you start
breaking down this debt that you have
that's in the way of all this
yeah so uh total debt is about a hundred
and sixty thousand 120 of that is my
house
um I've got about 3 700 on a credit card
and uh 18
000 and personal loans two personal
loans
eighteen thousand and two personal loans
how much are they a piece
uh one of them is about uh ten thousand
the other one's about eight
well I don't know how long you've been
listening to us
um but we do teach to get out of debt
before you would do anything close to
what you're talking about doing so I
kind of just want to break that down
with you piece by piece and then you
know take take it or leave it I would
say
um okay the good thing about it is
you've got thirty seven thousand dollars
worth of debt 120 of it it's your house
so what we say is pay off everything but
the house
for now
so what's your income looking like so
let's see if we can find this margin
uh before taxes this year so I'm an hour
hourly based employees but we do work a
lot of overtime but so our our income it
does vary but as of right now it's
looking like I'll make somewhere between
120 and 130 this year okay and is that
just you or do you have a spouse
no that's just me that's just you are
you do you have spouse
no okay so 120 man
can you
um savings
I'm sorry what do you have anything in
savings or non-retirement investing
um no no nothing is besides a 401k
um I do have
around a hundred thousand and a 401k
right now
um and then as far as savings uh it's
probably about five six thousand five
six thousand okay well what we would say
we walked through a series of baby steps
okay are you familiar with any of those
or will this be your first time hearing
it
this will be my first time here and I'm
I'm actually just now hearing about Dave
Ramsey I heard about you guys maybe a
month ago great well I'm happy to
explain this to you because welcome to
the place
we're so excited I'm Lane I'm
I'm excited right now because I love the
baby steps they work and so I love
telling people about it okay baby step
one is you need to get or keep aside a
thousand dollars saved that's your
starter emergency fund that's just it's
not it's not forever it's just temporary
good thing is you've got five thousand
saved we keep a thousand of that aside
then you can take the four thousand put
it towards this debt knock that down to
thirty three thousand right
right and then baby step two is paying
off your debt like I said before accept
your house so that's we're knocking out
the rest of that thirty four thousand
thirty three thousand and with your
income you could do that so super fast
it's just you right
yeah all you got to do is control trips
to the bar yeah
that's it well uh well luckily I'm not
I'm not a big fan of the bar good well
let me keep we're making so much
progress so fast here it's unbelievable
I know let's temporarily stop your 401k
temporarily let's get some scissors out
and place them across those credit cards
and have a plastic surgery party okay
okay we're done with those we're gonna
get a debit card we're not spending any
money we don't have anymore it hadn't
turned into a blessing for you and then
we're going to go scorched Earth where
you have no life
your whole right be your whole reason
for existence is to pay off debt as fast
as possible as if your hair were on fire
the faster and the deeper you sacrifice
the higher the probability that you
actually get out of debt number one but
number two obviously the faster you get
to this goal that you called about which
is going to reach over later and pay off
the house with a little less intensity
um and then we're going to be in a
position to save for uh you know save up
and pay cash for Real Estate yeah and
thirty seven thousand dollars in credit
card debt it's three thousand seven
hundred yeah so
quicker than what I was credit cards
gone yeah your credit cards done
immediately paid off today and then
you've just got that 18 000 loans to
work through you're gonna do smallest to
largest that's how we pay off our debts
you're going to do the eight thousand
dollar one first and then you're gonna
move to the ten thousand dollar one and
dude I gear quote Me Now by the end of
the year all your debt's gonna be gone
and then you're going to save up three
to six months of savings and you're just
gonna walk this thing through you'll be
able to restart your
um retirement and baby step four back to
15 and you're just gonna walk this thing
through and before you know it you're
gonna be set up in a position to where
you could save up to buy real estate and
cash Lane it's exactly what I did and
the book we wrote about it is called The
Total Money Makeover and I own a whole
bunch of real estate now all paid for
never took out a mortgage for any of it
and when there's problems well cash flow
isn't one of them
so um that's a different situation so
hang on we're going to send you a copy
of that book The Total Money Makeover
it's going to give you the it's the baby
steps on steroids it shows you every
little Nuance every little detail
because I can tell you're a guy that
figures things out and we're going to
show you you read this thing you're
going to be on fire you're going to plow
if you do what we teach you to do you're
going to be in such good shape in such a
short period of time the good news is
you don't have to talk any spouse into
this the bad news is there's nobody
nagging on you to make you do it except
me
so I'll be here to nag you that's my job
and if and if I don't work I'll send
Jade after that I don't know which one
is worse I don't know which one's more
frightening
hang on Lane we'll take care of you my
friend welcome to the party all right
you gotta love it John's in Ocala
Florida hey John what's up
how you doing Dave thank you for taking
my call
um can you uh kind of new listener to
the series here I've been kind of binge
watching this uh episodes there on
YouTube uh for the last couple days here
I figured I'd call in
um I been pretty Frugal most of my life
I don't have any debt uh me and my
fiance both don't have any debt
um I purchased property uh pre-covered
and in the intention of building and
then code would kind of happened and we
put things on hold which looking back on
interest rates now I kind of wish I
wouldn't have
um I've always been with my parents for
a few years now and have this property
and we need to build and uh and get out
so uh planning on building shortly
um but I have a decent down payment
um well I've actually got more than the
20 on what I'm assuming we're going to
need to have uh and that was going to be
my question as far as should I put more
into my down payment to knock down the
loan as far as possible because of the
higher interest rate or what now on my
20 and then over time just kind of pay
on you know almost double payments every
every other month or something like that
John I'd love to answer your question in
just a second let me ask you something
okay go ahead do you realize that when
you started telling me about building
that your side
yeah I know
as from the beginning I've been through
all my life I've never had any kind of
debt and pre-covered my own building so
it's not it's not dreading the actual
building project
I'm going to be in debt and I want this
out okay now let me let's go back to
your question then if you don't want to
be in debt why would you borrow on your
house to invest
so I don't have a house I know hon you
called me and said I don't want to put
as much down because I think it might be
smart to put in the stock market that's
just like borrowing on your house to put
it into the to put it in the stock
market that's it follow me
so put as much down as you possibly can
by the way all the studies of
millionaires that we've done indicate
that's the right move it's what they do
they don't screw around with that they
get out of it as fast as they can almost
universally very few actual millionaires
I'm not talking about idiots on Tick
Tock I'm talking about actual
millionaires very few actual
millionaires love debt very few of them
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host Sherry is next in Salem Oregon
hi Sherry welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you for taking that call sure how
can I help
well
I guess the question is
um
I'm having trouble hearing Johnny can
you speak directly into your phone
that's okay
barely it's kind of muffled but let's
give it a shot what you got
okay I'm almost 69 years old
and
um
I just finished baby step one
um I got my my emergency fund
and I'm starting on babysit too however
I know that because I've been listening
to your program for a while I know that
you encourage people to
um buy real estate by atrocity
a house
and
I have no siblings I mean I have
siblings but I have no no children
uh no husband
and I live in a travel trailer that I
rent property
um
is it really worth it for me to
that 69 years old to buy from buy a
house after I get my baby stuff done
it's not worth it to stress about it
um
but the
um what are you living on what's your
income
um I get uh approximately
1600 a month
mm-hmm
950 of that are 9 95 of that is Social
Security and then the rest of it is a
Civil Service survivors annuity
from my husband when he passed away okay
and that's your entire income
that's my entire income how's your
health
not real good okay what are you
struggling with
as far as health yes ma'am
um uh well I'm pre-diabetic I but
fibromyalgia I've got asthma I've got
I got a whole list of things bipolars
yeah okay
well I more than anything I want you to
be out of debt and have a big pile of
cash for an emergency
I'm a lot more concerned about that with
you I would spend 99 of my effort if I
were you on that
if something changes in your world
and some extra money shows up and you
want to think about a house you could do
that but there's not a house in the
numbers you just told me
and um and and also didn't hear
I I think you're pretty content housing
wise aren't you
actually I like living in a little
travel trailer I thought you kind of
like that place and everything the only
downside of that as a Long play is 10
years from now that lot price is going
to be a lot more it's going to increase
more than your Social Security and civil
service is going to increase
probably oh not probably 100 chance of
that
the government does not that when they
inflation adjust it's not the same as
the uh trailer park uh lot guy inflation
adjusting he's going to adjust more
so if you you know if you may if you
make it to 79 it's going to be more of a
pinch than you have now but you won't
have any debt and you'll have a pile of
money because we're going to build up in
a big emergency fund so I'm okay if
that's your play the big reason we want
people to buy a house is just stability
and renting goes up rent goes up and it
destabilizes it takes their stability
away you hear what I'm saying
yes
I do yeah I I would do the same thing I
heard what Dave heard in your voice
which is you're content with what you
have it doesn't sound like you're in a
condition to just go out and make a
bunch more money here anytime soon so
for you the thing to focus on is getting
out of this you know keeping what you
have building up a big savings how much
debt do you have
I have about fifteen thousand on what
and most of that is
um
medical bills okay all right and how old
are those medical bills
um
some of them are
probably range anywhere from about uh 10
years yeah now okay anything over one
year they will take 20 cents on the
dollar for if you negotiate with them
oh awesome the only thing is you need to
have the cash ready to go yeah if you
got a little pilot build up a little
pile of cash and then call that thousand
dollar bill and tell them I don't have a
thousand I got 200 if you'll take it
right now and you've got a four-year-old
medical bill they're going to be just
happy to hear from you
that's good yeah now you need to do that
on a day when you're feeling kind of uh
kind of sassy a feisty day and feisty
you don't need to do that on a day when
you're feeling down okay
okay that makes sense
so let's so bottom line is I think you
get out of debt for say four or five
grand six grand in this situation maybe
so you're gonna work your way through
this with some negotiating power and
some other things
um and you know when you pile up a big
old pile of cash if you decide you want
to move that trailer onto a little piece
of land and you buy the land well that
wouldn't be a bad move
yeah but but that's something we don't
have to fret about and it's not like
you're a bad person if you don't do that
I'm just trying to get your life stable
and anytime I can get rent out of your
life has a long-term play yeah it
stabilizes your life that's what I want
to do there yeah all she's got to do is
you know stack up every time she gets
500 stack it up call them make a deal
keep it in writing forever stack up
another five dollars call make another
deal until she's out of this debt good
good clarification point in writing if
they don't give it if a collector
doesn't give you a deal in writing it
didn't happen that's right because you
can tell they're lying if their mouth is
moving
and so you've got to get it in writing
and no electronic access to your
checking account your social security
check will hit and they'll clean you out
yeah so do not allow them access to your
account under any circumstances and
under no circumstances do you give them
money on a verbal promise on the phone
well Harold tell me Well Harold doesn't
work here anymore this is what you'll
hear okay and Harold wouldn't have done
something like that anyway you're lying
lady you still owe the whole bill well
I've already paid 200 that's what no you
owe the whole bill you're gonna it's
what you're going to hear if you don't
get it in writing and uh not like I
haven't done this 10 000 times okay so
you just need to be a little sassy with
them and make sure you get it in writing
and no electronic access to your
checking account try to settle it for 20
cents on the dollar I'll bet you can
settle most of them for that go ahead
and explain to them by the way you're a
widow that lives in Social on Social
Security in a travel trailer right it's
not exactly like your Prime picking for
collections
so you're what we call judgment proof
because you can't garnish your social
security or civil service so you they
can't take your income yeah only thing
to do is clean your account out if you
let they go into your account so you
gotta be careful don't give them account
information ever so uh and they don't
want a travel trailer so they're not
going to bother you
um but the uh but but they're going to
talk big and that's why you need to have
your swag on your sassy on yeah turn
your swag on and um that's a good day
right that's that's the plan
a little Little Swagger when you walk in
the room let them feel it that's how it
goes because it's what it takes
absolutely you got to bust through it
because these poor people sitting in
cubicles making phone calls people not
paying bills all day long are not easy
to get along with well sometimes you
have to bug them as much as they bugged
you you know that's a bad gun proof you
know you have to drive them crazy they
call you every day you call them every
day leave a message Mike get your
personal home number so I can call you
on Sunday night Mike did you make the
deal yet I'm waiting for the paperwork
call them at dinner time I love it can I
find out where you live so I can call
your next door neighbor yeah let's do
that one that's that's one they do
that's illegal as crap but yeah the
federal fair debt collection practices
act gives you folks all kinds of
protection when you are being harassed
by a collector learn it it's good
information it is good information I
didn't know that back in the day no and
and you know the fun ones are they
change their names I had one I had one
lady call me and she she met these made
up pseudonyms her name was Mrs
Baskerville the hounds of Baskerville
yeah another one was Mrs Savage that wow
okay I started laughing I said you're no
more Savage than anything and she goes
that ain't funny it's my real name I
said no it's not your name you
completely made that crap up that's when
you make your name up this is not Dave
Mrs Savage this is Mr Cyclops there you
go come on right here one eye in the
center of my head oh brother
these people
some people's kids is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
over your head with student loans and
tired of getting calls from collection
agencies if private student loan debt is
taking away your financial piece and you
don't see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with why refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump sum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America we're glad you're
here Jade wash all Ramsey personality is
my co-host today we're glad you're with
us this is your show we talk about you
right in front of you the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five Kevin is starting off this hour
in Nashville hi Kevin welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
got a question about uh the dollar
assuming the record inflation and uh the
brics Nations
and uh
come across some information recently
that there's highly anticipated Summit
that they're doing on October 26 or
August 22nd
and uh people are expecting them to
announce their own
gold-backed currency they say these five
nations represent 40 percent
of uh Global GDP and Saudi Arabia is
thrown their hat in the ring with them
so the rumors are if Saudi joins them
and drops the dollar then we lose the
petrol Dollar in every country that
holds treasury bonds to buy oil from the
Saudis it's their dollars and all those
dollars come home and cause catastrophic
inflation
um
how much of this is substantial what do
you think about bricks is is there any
real threat here or anything to do to
prepare or is it just another passing
bit of fear-mongering
well I I think the um there's a lot of
discussion about it particularly uh if
you read too much on the internet but
the uh um
my you know you're asking my opinion and
that's worth really everything you're
paying for it um the uh
my opinion is that Russia and China
uh probably can't get the Saudis to the
table because the Saudis are probably
way too smart to think they're going to
undermine the U.S economy
oh by the way undermining the U.S
economy would not be profitable for all
of those other companies countries
because they're supported by the U.S
economy
um and so if 40 percent of the GDP kills
60 percent of the GDP
kind of kills the whole thing it's God
is stupid
so uh no they're not going to kill
themselves by killing us that's
economically uh it's just it's it's
counterproductive and the idea that you
can get all of those Communists to line
up and not try to shoot each other
is going to be humorous on the Long play
they might be able to do it in one day
in August but are they actually going to
pull this off listen they couldn't pull
the Euro Euro off in Europe
to the level that it had any effect on
anything
and those people all get along
versus the group you're talking about so
I think it's a you know I they they're
working on it but I don't think that the
chances that it's going to change your
life or change my life is there
personally
if it did do everything you're talking
about I don't prepare for meteorites
I don't have a meteorite plan if a
meteorite strikes the Earth and kills
everything I don't have a plan for that
and I'll have a plan for Apocalypse like
you're talking about so uh there's not
one by the way because what you have
then is you have a total economic and
governmental collapse and the only plan
then that works is bottled water and
bullets
uh gold is a joke because no one trades
gold bars in the middle of a collapsed
economy and certainly no one trades
paper money in a collapsed economy but
the US government our way of life as we
know it private property rights as we
know it all the real estate I own would
be taken by the next guy with a gun
and so uh you know bullets and water is
how you'd survive I guess but I just
don't believe I'm not I I am not
stockpiling either
uh except that bullets go up too fast in
price and I shoot a lot but but that's
not that's your role but the the so all
that to say I'm not sitting and wringing
my hands over it I do have some
um friends that spend too much time
reading that crap that are ringing their
hands over it uh but I I had a big
argument with one of them the other
night I'm like dude you really need to
get off the internet yeah
um and so uh because you can't a you
can't do anything about it if it
actually all unfolded the way you did
but B the theory is broken and the
broken parts of the theory is that you
can get all these people to agree
and number and stay agreed because
they're evil at their core evil people
cannot continually agree because they
serve themselves and don't serve others
and so it can't you can't find unity in
that long term number two
if they represent 40 of the economy and
they use 40 of the world's economy which
I'm not sure that number is accurate I
think that's pretty high but if it was
that and if for and if they destroyed
sixty percent of the economy by doing
this
then they've destroyed themselves in the
process because they everything they do
hinges on the you freaking s hello I
mean it really does and that's that's
just that's economic mathematics so now
I'm not worried about it I'm a I'm a
control the controllables type gal yeah
you know like you that's like one of
those Serenity Prayer moments where it's
like I just need the serenity to realize
I can't control this I'm not I have no
idea if there's aliens yeah yeah and
UFOs and if they take over I mean I
guess I'm gonna call Will Smith because
I don't you know I don't I can't I can't
I don't have a plan for that one you
know yeah I don't control what Saudi
Arabia only aliens I'm guessing there's
no idea oh no yeah it looks or somebody
throws a lot of Frisbees in front of
cameras but you know I have no idea and
you know what I'm the time I'm gonna
spend worrying about it is really close
to zero Kevin I
close to zero so I
I got your question and it was Earnest
and honest question I honestly do not
spend any of my
time planning my personal finances or my
life around the end of the world that's
right into the world scenarios and I
have also made one other promise a lot
of guys in the financial World when they
get old like me they write the end of
the world financial book there's
something about people in my world
they're not going to predict the end
they get they get paranoid and they
predict the end of the economy they
predict the end of the world and there's
a lot of old Financial people that did
that and I'm not going to do that one
either I told my kids take to unplug the
computer if I start writing about the
end of the financial world so I'm I'm
the glass half full control the
controllables yeah I think we're going
to be okay and I'm not making fun of you
Kevin it's an honest question and the
numbers you gave me were very precise
and accurate and other than I think
those guys are overstating
it well of course they over 30 they're
Russians they're over their egos they
overstate everything I mean the only
bigger drama queen than a Russian and is
an American so I mean they're drama
queens so of course they're acting like
they're got something they haven't got
yeah you know they're starving to
freaking death the whole the whole
communism thing oh here's a here's
another one for you read a credible
Economist the other day said in 20 years
you ain't got to worry anything about
China you know why
they got no workers that's birthday good
birth rate hasn't been negative for two
decades yeah because they're controlling
the the birth rate and so the number of
people that are going to be eligible in
the workforce is gone that's a very good
point so their ability to be a major
economic player in 25 years very low
they killed themselves with their birth
rate wow this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five thanks for being with
us
our question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services Home Improvement isn't always
about repairs or remodels sometimes it's
about Comfort neighborly's mosquito Joe
service can handle your outdoor pest
control and make it fun and comfortable
to go outside all season long visit
neighborly.com to find a service near
you today's question comes
Oklahoma he says I have two Bachelor
degrees the second in nursing with a
hundred and eighty thousand in student
loans I travel nurse during covid and
was able to save up a lot of cash and
haven't touched it knowing that debt the
debt pause would be ending soon I just
took a clinical specialist role with a
great company and I'm on track to get
into sales in the next two years I'll be
making 125 000 salary and I currently
have a hundred thousand in cash spread
around secure investing accounts making
a guaranteed 4.6 percent growth year
over year I'm asking for any guidance on
how to approach these student loans I am
engaged and do not want to bury my
finance with student loans all right
good question
um I'm glad that he started saving up
money uh knowing that he was going to
have to pay off these loans I kind of
wish he had just went ahead and made the
payments instead of you know keeping it
there
um but it looks like he's got a hundred
thousand saved it sounds like it's just
an hysa based on the rate even though he
said their investing accounts would you
agree with that Dave uh could be could
be bonds I don't know hmm if it doesn't
matter whatever it is I would liquidate
that and I would today pay off these
student loans I mean you're gonna have
25k let's see you're gonna have 80k left
and you can just
a fiance with student loans if you're
getting married anytime soon because
you're making 125 about 25 and you've
still got 80k in debt but depending on
when y'all are getting married you might
have if you take this job and you hustle
your butt off you might could have this
paid off before you get married if the
if the wedding is a year away I don't
know but the the truth of the matter is
go ahead and pay them off and for
anybody by the way if you've got cash a
lump sum of cash I don't care how much
cash it is if you've got cash sitting
there and you're saying to yourself hey
I don't want to pay this off but you've
got debt it's not real
it's not real like basic math tells you
if you've got 80 000 in debt and you've
got 80 000 saved you got zero that 80
000 saved is It's Just an Illusion so
throw the 100 at the debt today today
quit screwing around and trying to
figure out a way to scheme out of this
you got to pay it off gotta roll up your
sleeves and go headlong into it like a
crazy man that's right here's the other
thing dude 125 000 clinical specialist
uh you're still a nurse uh so you're now
working ER on the weekends there you go
we're going to add another 40K to your
income because you don't want to be a
burden to your fiance and you're going
to live on beans and rice rice and beans
nothing no eating out no travel no
nothing yeah you get this mess cleaned
up you made a mess mess before you start
anything you got to clean up the mess
mess mess yeah so here's what we're
gonna do we'll work like a maniac and
we're gonna live on nothing
and you're gonna pay this on pay this
loan off pay this hundred thousand
that's right nothing nothing remember
that commercial nut he's gonna go into
that wedding with nothing honey that's
it oh do you remember that some cereal
yeah they can serve that at the
reception
honey that's what I'm bringing that's a
debt I'm bringing into this marriage
nothing honey I know that's right there
you go we just made up we did look at
that yeah all right so yeah
you can pay this off but you're going to
work like a maniac and you're going to
live like people think you joined a cult
yeah and you're going to go crake right
here get this knocked out man and let's
address that wedding
you don't need to spend a bunch on the
wedding you need to knock out these
loans and let me tell you about the
spirit of I'm going to invest and make a
spread a 4.6 let me tell you what that
got you nothing
in one year if you had a if you had zero
on your student loans which is what you
had and you made 4.6 percent on a
hundred thousand you know what you made
four thousand six hundred dollars well
aren't you impressive you still got a 80
000 freaking problem while you're
screwing around with these little flippy
dudes that don't do anything a whole
four thousand dollars on a hundred grand
whoopee yeah you didn't do nothing get
it paid off now and lean in that's what
you do this is let me tell you guys the
when you start being I'm a math nerd
extraordinaire and I tried four years to
try to get the math to outsmart the debt
yeah the only way you knock out the debt
is you punch it in the nose repeatedly
that's it it's that's it and if that
doesn't work hit it with a club if that
doesn't work stab it with a knife kill
it kill it kill it dead this is this is
someone robbing your home we are
merciless yeah okay no no quit screwing
around with some kind of little four
thousand dollar math riddle yeah and act
like you did something pay off your debt
now everyone listen to this this is how
you get out of debt you get this thing
in your voice where you go that's it I
and that's when you it doesn't move
until it doesn't move doesn't move it
doesn't move Come On Dave gotta get
pissed it doesn't work until you do man
I'm trying to figure this out with my
little math nerd brain and all I did was
make a mess all right Roman is in
Orlando hi Roman how are you
hey Mr Dave how are you doing better
than I deserve how can I help
uh yes hi Miss Jade hey what's going on
a question uh
my question is
um should I stop or reduce my
contributions to my 457 in order to pay
off my mortgage sooner rather than later
and by sooner I mean probably by
February of next year with your mortgage
your third child is due your mortgage
correct how come it says car on my
screen
either the mortgage or the car but my
wife uh told me no the mortgage is not
the car and I was like oh okay your
wife's wrong
oh probably a novel idea for her but
she's wrong
I forgot to mention that yeah I noticed
that too if you're in baby step two if
you're in baby step two you would pause
in investing contributions but if you
would attack your car loan yes because
that would be part of baby step two
so that's how that works if you pay off
the car but what do you owe on your car
yeah
uh 24. and what's your household income
uh single income one about 120. okay
let's get it good and um what do you owe
on your house
uh 48 okay all right thousand yeah we're
gonna pay off the car
a media I mean money and savings
uh we do actually we have a we have 35
000 in savings and 20 of that is a uh
pay off your car off your car today
now
write a check tonight
stop your for and then you don't have to
stop your 457 by the way you build your
emergency fund so babies you're fairly
new to us Roman and we're picking on you
I'm sorry because you don't you don't
know you don't know all this stuff you
just walked into the bear's den yeah you
did you did I'm sorry so let's start
let's start let's start let's start
again and we'll start nice okay here's
nice now what we teach is a thing called
the baby steps and the first step is a
thousand dollars saved you've done that
step two is to become debt free other
than your home this is the fastest way
to wealth
as proven by the largest study of
millionaires ever done okay
so this is not a game and it's not an
accident it's not something we made up
because we're on YouTube or some crap
okay this is stuff we've been doing for
30 years and we've LED more people out
of debt and into wealth than anybody
else this is the process we use baby
step two is pay off everything but your
house that would be your car in your
case and you have the money oddly enough
in your account to write a check today
and do that right
yes yes we do actually so now you're
debt free now then baby step three other
than your house baby step three is have
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses if you don't quite have that
left over after you pay off the car
let's round that up real quick maybe
step four is fifteen percent of your
income going into retirement I would
prefer a 401k or Roth IRAs over a 457 a
457 is just Deferred Comp
so I'd prefer to do that unless you're
getting a match there that wouldn't be
my first stop and then with any money I
can find the budget I'm Gonna Knock Out
this little bitty mortgage you got and
I'll be on your wife's team at that
point but it takes me a while to get to
your wife's team hey thanks for calling
in man this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones are triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jade I gotta do a
better job remembering so many people
calling her brand new yeah because like
a whole bunch of new listeners out there
like bazillions of them Brazilians thank
you guys for spreading the word out
there we appreciate it if you subscribe
to this show if you click the Subscribe
button click the follow button on your
podcast or YouTube or however it is
you're doing it it helps us a bunch
because it pushes us to the front we're
now in the top 12 Apple podcast as an
example in the entire world
there's four million and some change
podcasts right now we're number 12.
this week so thank you and we know that
that's you guys doing that you're
sharing it you click the share button
you're telling people about it you're
telling people to listen to your local
talk radio station we appreciate that
anywhere you're picking us up tell
people where we are drop a five star
review if that's available to you as
well that's very helpful and so we're
getting all these brand new listeners
and and I got to be nicer to them well
we've got it we don't want to kill the
new listeners it's counterproductive
that's true we have to teach them more
than we can yell at them yeah well I
know I just don't want to kill them I
mean like we can yell at them but we
can't yeah I like yelling I'm not gonna
lie it's it's fun it's
you like yelling too David minute I I
just tried to be nice and look at what
you're doing all right Samantha is in
Salt Lake City hey Samantha what's up
hey Dave hey Jay how are you too better
than we deserve what's up yes I'm so
glad I get to talk to both of you um so
um
I am 37 years old and I'm just uh
getting the baby step one I'm working on
it but I've also been a long time
listener since like 2019 so I'm not new
to the game okay I actually got to talk
to you Dave a couple of years ago
um
you were very nice good you were very
nice but very direct and that's what I
appreciate that's what we want to be
I'll tell you the truth today
yes yes and I appreciate that I love
your show I listened to it all the time
um the reason I'm calling today is it's
hard to be motivated even though I know
that I need to do this and I know that
it's going to change my life for the
better
um I'm working so much and I'm um and
it's getting to the point where I'm like
working so much and I'm not spending a
lot and I mean I get why I need to do
that but I guess my question is more for
Jay today because I know Jade's story
and Jay I just wanted to ask you
directly when you're in that debt and
you were trying to get out of it what
was the main motivation for you when you
were like oh this this is like draining
it's so hard to just work and not spend
what kept you motivated kept kept going
how long you been doing this
um hardcore where you're working all the
time and not spending
about six months okay okay thank you
um to answer your question
I had I had a couple of things I had a
very crystal clear picture in my mind of
what my life was going to look like on
the other side
very very clear it was me walking down a
street uh walking my son to school I
knew the way I felt I was I had no debt
I was living in a home uh that we were
affording I was
um in a situation of autonomy I had a
very very clear picture and it was peace
and it was totally not my current
situation because at the time there was
no way I would be buying a house because
I had so much debt you know the story so
having that picture there
um is so important and no one can find
that for you you've got to dig deep and
figure out like why am I doing this am I
doing this because it you know there's
got to be something beyond the math
generally now for some people math is
enough yeah you gotta have a while you
gotta have something in there that is
driving it's it's
um it's not optional it must happen I
definitely have a wife okay what's your
why it's hard to stay focused on that
sometimes my why is to be able to just
have peace like you guys talk about all
the time financial piece being able to
go into a restaurant and not look at the
price and just learn what you want or
you know like going to
um a grocery store and I'm in line and
then the person behind me you know is a
is a mom that has two kids and I'm like
you know what
I'll just take care of that you know
just to be outrageous outrageously
generous and be and be how old are you
Samantha how old are you
37 years old okay are you married
no I have um I have a fiance that we've
been together for about three years so
and and that's mainly that's he's my
biggest why
um okay and I I want us to both be a
power couple and be able to
um you know conquer the world together
and we can only do that with
um being financially stable and he's
awesome he's got he's got like thirty
thousand dollars in the bank know that
he uh has over a hundred thousand
dollars in 401ks how much do you have in
debt
I had about thirty thousand dollars in
debt and then what do you make
about
um
actually I haven't pulled up I think I
make um I'd make 29 a month and so again
33 600.
what do you do
I am I do a lot so I do what's your main
game important
a technical support for a diabetes
company or work from home
and that pays 25k
it pays 18 bucks an hour
okay and they work full time
all right and um and uh
is that what you want to be doing
is that what you I mean
I mean yes I I definitely find um I
definitely find purpose in my job
because
um I get to talk to people and get to
help them all the time and I'm also
diabetic so I could relate to the
customers is there something that here I
want to challenge you with a couple of
things one is there something that you
could do in that same field where you're
helping people you're helping diabetics
you're relating to people where they are
where you can earn more money because I
think that you can I think your skill
set's more valuable than twenty five
thousand dollars
yeah I did too like I I've been in
customer service for a long time
um but yeah like I I've been definitely
trying I'm definitely looking but I'm
also doing pet sitting and doing
taskrabbits which is right when are you
getting married income
I would say probably next year you would
say so you don't have a date set
no not yet why
um I our main focus right now is to
is working on some stuff with his mental
health like it's not that he's
unmentually unstable but and I'm mainly
just working on getting out of debt and
getting financially stable is the mental
health thing a caveat to whether you
marry him or not
no no no no he's he's it's more about
him getting being ready to marry me
interesting that sounds interesting I'm
not gonna lie you you've been engaged
for three years I need to be more
financially stable yeah you've been in
you've been engaged for three years
no we've been together for three years
we've only been engaged probably about
three months can I ask you something did
he um did he does he want you to be debt
free before you get married
no he just wants to be able for me to be
able to prove that I can follow a budget
and be financially disciplined and I
don't think that's too much to ask
you got to get your income up
that's that's key
um
you've been together three years
you said you've been listening since
2019.
this debt that you have is it old debt
or have you been creating new debt since
you met him because I'm basically trying
to understand his question
I'm basically trying to understand his
point of saying I want to prove that
you're not a princess basically but my
question is well if you haven't been
creating any more debt if you made it
and if you've been 33 you might be a
princess but at 33 000 you're not a
princess and she's not it's not like
she's been taking on more debt Dave this
is old debt she's proven herself I don't
like the way I don't like I don't like
what this guy is saying to you
something something
there's something wrong in Paradise
um it's troubled something something I
don't know what it is but yeah okay we
got to get your income up on uh because
you're not making any money at 37 years
old you're close to the poverty level so
let's do some things on your career if I
were you hang on we're going to send you
Kane Coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose and help you move that direction
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Christina is with us in
Huntsville hi Christina welcome to the
Ramsey Show
so all that you do for everybody well
thank you how can we help
yeah my question is I have a 2014 Buick
LaCrosse I owe 5000 on it and the
transmission has gone out we've called
around and got the lowest quote we got
it it started at 6 500 now it's at 5 000
it's the cheapest one that we can get
um my husband and I are looking to move
in February back home to Washington
state from where we are now and my
parents have a car that they can just
give me and my thought after talking to
some other people that do Dave Ramsey is
to let this car go and just get what we
can get for it and the condition that
it's in and go with just one car we're
both self-employed we don't have to have
two cars it's not like I have eight to
five I have to get two and
um to take that extra money that instead
of having to pay 5000 to get it fixed
and I'm trying to pay off my debt we're
both working on paying off our debt
um we wouldn't have to pay the 5 000 for
the repair we wouldn't have to pay 5000
for the car
um I'd save 500 a month by not paying
Insurance in my monthly payment
um so I am of the mindset of letting the
car go and taking my parents car in
February when you say Let It Go Let It
Be repoed
no sir I'm sorry I when I say let it go
I just probably because I'm emotionally
attached to my car
what can you get for it what can you get
for it with no transmission yep I looked
at that I did put that into Kelly Blue
Book and it would be either right at
what we owe possibly a little bit more
somewhere in that not with no
transmission you're getting
it doesn't have a transmission it's not
drivable but that was what it said
but let's let's just assume I'm wrong
who do you owe the five thousand dollars
to
my credit union okay all right you're
not going to get 5K for the car I don't
think I could be wrong I hope you do I
wish you would it's a very it's a very
it's the same if it's worth five I
thought it was worth five thousand
dollars what was it worth with the
transmission in it
oh if I had the transmission eight to
ten okay
oh no it doesn't depend what's it worth
with the transmission in it
the price ranges they give gave with a
functional car was eight to ten and with
it without the transmission it was five
that makes more sense okay you might get
5'4 then okay so you wouldn't take the
five and buy another car you would no
she got to pay off the loan no
I wanted that's my uh that's our plan if
you can get 5K for it and 100 of the
time I'm doing what you want to do
that's yes I meant
okay if you don't get 5K for it I'm
still selling it
and asking the credit union for the to
loan you're the to let you shine a note
for the difference
okay because you don't have any money
saved right
we do I could I could pay off the
difference I wouldn't have to get a loan
we have a little a little
bag over there it's I mean small like
three three thousand we're both sales
employed so we have our tax money that
we set aside we sprayed off the top of
every check yeah dump the car sell the
car
okay I'm with you I think I like your
plan here's the thing here's the formula
for everybody out there and for you okay
if the car is worth eight thousand
dollars fixed it's worth five thousand
or four thousand dollars and the repair
is let's let's call the work car worth
four if the repair is five and five and
four you now have nine thousand dollars
in a car that's only worth eight you
don't fix that car
right so if you're driving a hoop D
that's three thousand dollars and
somebody comes in with a thousand dollar
repair you don't do that you dump the
car for Salvage and go get you another
throwaway car
um and yours is borderline hoopty it's
not quite all the way down to hoopty I
mean it's eight thousand dollar car
fixed or nine thousand dollar car fixed
okay so yours is questionable and the
other possibility and I wouldn't do it
here I like your plan better is to buy a
used transmission that fits it from a
salvage yard
uh we did look at that too and it was
still it was the the labor that kills
you to to get those kinds of things done
um
that you can shop
okay okay but I I think you could
probably do it for half of what you're
talking about but I'm still dumping this
car I love your idea and you can you're
gonna sweat it out till you make the
move with one car and that gets rid of
the debt right
yes yes yeah I like I like your
willingness to sacrifice I like the plan
it's a lot of freedom in it it kind of
breathes good doesn't it you like you
breathe good when you're talking about
it right even though you cry just a
little bit because you like that car
yeah I do yeah my husband uh likes to
have definitely uh two cars but I am
totally down like I am totally of the
mindset that I'm just willing to do
whatever it takes come on where we want
to be yeah I like you Christina I could
tell from the moment you started talking
you weren't making excuses you were
willing to do what it takes I love that
you can hear it you know January
February would be here pretty fast
that's right it will yes yeah just blink
and it'll be here I mean it was just 20
minutes ago it was here I know right I
don't even know what month we're in now
I'm just rolling
it goes really fast Jake's in Texas Hey
Jake welcome to the Ramsey Show
better than we deserve how can we help
venturing into the exciting and
stressful world of home buying and uh
I am trying to consolidate and get all
my debts paid off and just trying to do
this the right way because uh that sucks
what's your question
um well currently I've uh
I have let's see I have three major
debts I guess you would say uh my truck
my wife's car and I have one credit card
that is very close to being paid off
um what are the amounts of each
um I owe 17 000 on my truck
um my wife's car is almost done uh oh 2K
2000 on her car
and 2 400 on the credit card
and currently I've bumped up I'm trying
to attack that car because it's my
lowest one
um and I got it bumped up to where I'm
paying 600 every two weeks right now I'm
trying to really attack and get that one
out of my way yeah
what's that what's your question Jake
um
should I should I get all of this debt
even my truck gone before I commit to a
house
yes
what made you here's what I want to ask
you what made you ask that question
because I think you know the answer to
it
um I mean I've been up to debt in my
eyeballs before and I'm finally out of
that and you know I just uh I don't want
to go back into that but I'm with a I'm
with a job now that um I'm doing very
well and what's your household income
um well I actually I'm it's just me that
works my wife's stay-at-home mom she
homeschools and stuff so I'm I'm the
main source of income but um about it
varies because I'm hourly but it's uh on
a normal month what do you see
um
about 9k 9 000 times 10. okay I think
that what your first instinct was
correct when you said I've been in debt
up to my eyeballs you don't want to
experience that because if you go and
get a mortgage right now it is not the
fact that you said you feel stressed
about this it's because you have this
debt when it's time to buy a house
you're going to be debt free you're
going to have a nice down payment saved
up you're gonna have three to six months
including expenses including your truck
okay you guys need to get on beans and
rice rice and beans and get this stuff
paid off and then save up your down
payment if you want to do it faster sell
your truck but I don't think you want to
do that so and you don't have to you
just have to you could be debt free in
about six months if you lean into this
pretty easy and you can pay more in your
paying by the way you know 600 things
wimpy on nine thousand dollar income
yeah so you need to lean in harder than
that like I want a house lean in like
I'm sick of this lean in like I'm pissed
and I'm getting out of debt lean in not
like I'm mildly aggravated no you can
get really angry at it and you need to
get on a budget I have a feeling they're
kind of just living in whatever's left
they're just talking they're throwing it
on the desk talking about it and acting
like we're doing something yeah you're
at the beginning stages my friend you're
going to do well but turn up the heat
and get this done so by next spring
you're buying a house with no debt and
your emergency fund in place plus a down
payment and that's what you do in the
spring and you bust it between now and
then that's what I would do this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
we're so glad you're here Marie's with
us in Chattanooga hi Marie welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi
better than we deserve what's up in your
world
so short question how do I ensure that
my parents don't end up homeless in
their retirement without them coming to
live with my husband and I so why is
that your job my husband is
because
um
I
my parents don't have anything safe for
retirement and for various reasons
um my that I experienced growing up my
husband and I are not okay with them
living with us in the future
um why is it your job to take care of
them
because I can see the trajectory that
they're on why is it your job to take
care of them
if they go in the street why is it your
job to get them out of the street
because they're my parents and I love
them and I don't want to see them
homeless
okay
it's not your here's where it's a desire
it's not your job it's something that
you like to do want to do and are
choosing to do
so don't don't pose the question in your
mind as if you are somehow forced
ethically or morally or spiritually into
doing this
now why why would your parents not have
any money why would they not at least
have social security
they would have social security but
um they're too irresponsible to pay
their house payment
they don't have a house right now
um where do they live now yeah
they are in the process of moving to
another state my father just got a new
job and
um with various moves in the past couple
of years all of the equity that they had
built up in the house that they
um owned when I was growing up has been
depleted the reason that I feel like I
want to give back and I don't want to
put my parents into this situation is
because
um
you didn't put them in this situation
they put themselves I'm not saying that
it's my fault I know it's their fault
you didn't put them in you should just
sit I put them in this situation you
didn't put them in the situation here's
the thing Marie the reason we're getting
you on your language is because the way
what you speak is a reflection of what
the way your heart feels so even though
you're saying I know I know I know what
you don't you don't because you keep
saying it it'll be if they end up like
this it'll be my fault I have to be the
one to help them if I don't do it no
like you keep putting that on yourself
and it's so important to make sure your
language is clear and the facts about
this are clear going in how old are your
mom and dad
they are 63. okay and your dad just got
a new job they're moving to another
state what's your dad going to be making
280.
thousand dollars a year
yes the reason is my parents have
um
my grandfather decided that he was going
to pay for my
um father and my uncle to go through
school and so my parents decided that
they were going to do that for us
so I don't have any debt because of that
and I am super super grateful for that
and I want to figure out I'm sorry
somewhere I got confused stop stop you
just went off the you just went off to
another planet
um I asked you if you're what your
father was going to be making in his new
job
000 dollars
yes
no is has he always earned an income
like that or is this just
it has been around the 200 000 mark this
answers the question this answers the
question okay stop you don't need to do
anything you need to look at your mom
and dad and say I love you
bye
you you know people that make 300 000 a
year and can't figure out a way to have
housing aren't your problem
this is asinine
Marie that you even have the feeling
that you have to prepare for the
homelessness of someone making 280 000
your family is dysfunctional dump some
crap on you and what do you make by the
way Marie
um I bring in 4 000 a month and my
husband brings in
3600. look no no no no no not in the
world girl
nope your dad makes 280 and the two of
you together don't make 90 and you
somehow got that this is your job
to prepare for their homelessness we're
not going to be making two they're not
going to be making 280 indefinitely oh
no kidding once that my father is unable
to work they won't have anything built
up and since that's their fault okay
with them living with us that's their
fault I'm aware of that let me tell you
the number of dollars I'm gonna give
this guy zero Marie they don't have to
live with you look they don't have to
live with you if he screws up a 280 000
income and ends up homeless that is not
on you
but it's not on you do not need to do
this I don't know what in the world has
gotten into you and by the way they're
not going to end up homeless it the
worst case scenario they're going to be
with people land on their feet
repeatedly yeah they lose everything and
get a job at 63 making 300 Grand this
guy lands on his feet like an alley cat
and he's got his daughter over here
making 40K worried about his
homelessness yeah
this is hey kiddo really you need to sit
down and see it you need to see a
counselor yeah because this is this is
deep stuff you are you are reflecting
back weird crap that happened in your
house growing up and I don't know what
it was but how in the world your mama
ends up a travel agent for guilt trips
on you is beyond me
I mean there is no possible way you end
up taking care of these people not in my
book nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope Dave dad does cocaine so
I have to take care of him no you don't
well you have to honor your father and
your mother the Bible says yes we honor
the position of fatherhood and
motherhood we do not honor the use of
cocaine
there's two different things if you
misbehave with 280 Grand to the point
you don't take care of your own
household that is not on your kids yeah
it's not and you know I I gotta say this
because I I
and I heard it in her and it has to be
addressed there is is a burden that kids
grown kids grown adult children face
when they see okay your parents they're
not doing what they should do and even
if you know it's not my job like it's
not my responsibility there is a part of
guilt that you feel that's like okay
that's like okay am I gonna be the one
that's gonna watch them you know go by
the wayside am I gonna let them live
like this and you but some point you
have to make peace if you're a kind
person
people that you love are hurting
you it's not it's not fun to watch
people you love doing stupid things if
you're a kind person if you're a good
person but it doesn't it doesn't make me
happy the people that I love or do
stupid things but it also doesn't make
me responsible yeah you have to make
peace with the fact that you're not
responsible for adult choices Henry
cloud has this wonderful book called
Boundaries you need to memorize it this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're glad you are here speaking
of Jade she is going to be doing this
Wednesday August the 9th a free free did
I mention is free budgeting webcast
that's pretty cool it is pretty cool
we're going to talk about all those pain
points that people deal with
day after day trying to do their budget
the things keeping people from doing a
budget right we're going to talk about
that we're going to address it we're
going to show you live on the screen how
this stuff works using our program every
dollar you're gonna walk away from it
feeling like huh I know what I'm doing
now
I feel like I got a raise and how to
deal with an irregular income yeah an
unpredictable income how do you budget
for that we're going to show you how to
do that with every dollar we've got a
thing called paycheck planning that is
one of the items in the robust app that
we have that was that was that's a good
word that's a good uh to internet term
yes it is robust robust robust it is it
really is these features will make
budgeting it just makes it a no-brainer
it makes it so easy of course a program
does all the math for you it helps you
decide when is the best day to actually
spend the money that you're saying
you're going to spend through your
budget so that you know no worries we're
gonna help you with that it's free I
will be the person uh guiding you
through that and let me tell you these
classes they fill up fast every time we
do these things they just sell out so
you need to sign up today if you want to
reserve a spot there you go check it out
everydollar.com budgeting this Wednesday
August the 9th the first webinar is free
Jade will be doing it uh we're gonna be
doing a bunch of these in the coming
weeks I will be letting you know and you
need to get in on this one if you want
to learn how to budget with Jade on
every dollar it's good stuff things are
happening out there I love it love it
love it
all right Aaron is with us in New York
City hi Erin welcome to the Ramsay show
Hi how are you guys
better than we deserve what's up
hi so I have kind of a two-part question
so my first question is I recently got
engaged and my fiance and I are getting
married next June congratulations thank
you so much we're looking for an
apartment for when we get married but we
are trying to do that without a credit
score good so I know so we've been
looking for apartments and some
apartments are saying they need credit
history or credit scores and we're just
wondering how to do that without credit
score like what are the steps we need to
take in order to get that done I don't
know how prevalent it is in New York
City but in other cities that we've done
research where we've actually called
like we're going call 20 different
apartment complexes we find that uh 75
to 80 percent of them don't require
anything the other 25 may require a
credit score or a deposit an extra
deposit but if you say hey look we're
newly married these are the jobs you
show them what you've got yeah you apply
for the apartment they do not solely
make the decision to run into department
on credit score now I'm not positive in
New York City if that's actually true
but I'm going to guess and say if the
rest of the nation's 75 percent at least
50 percent of the Departments there you
can do it with again they're looking
what a landlords looking for is can you
pay the rent right if you find one that
has a brain and you tell them hey I
don't have a bad credit score I just
don't have a credit score and you're
able to show them what you earn I do
yeah we do make this much money yeah uh
we are getting married and you know this
is what we're going to be making as a
household we easily can cover this
what's your normal deposit we can
definitely do that and so on you know
and you know but if you find someone
that only is going to make the decision
on credit score you found a corporate
goob okay you know what I'm saying
they're they're they got a ball they got
a boss in another city somewhere they're
not making any decisions they're they're
at the very bottom of the food chain and
they don't get to make any and
somebody's just put in place a random
policy you probably don't want to rent
there anyway that's true that's true
okay but you can you can find them
okay cool and thanks for the call man we
appreciate it so Anthony O'Neill that
was a Ramsey Personality yeah sat and uh
called her it's on YouTube and he sat
when he was here and called multiple
apartment complexes and said hey I'm
moving to Nashville I'm a single young
guy I got no credit score I got a job I
can show you my income and they said
sure that's fine mm-hmm and this idea
that you have to have a credit score to
run apartment by and large is just fall
Sean yeah that's just that's just one of
those lies people tell so that they
justify going in to get a credit card
and justify going into buying a car they
can't afford meaning they took out debt
on it yeah I mean the fact
to highlight this sometimes when you
choose to have a debt-free lifestyle
like it's not fair to say well if you
don't have a credit score we're going to
make you pay a little bit more first and
last months right that's
that that's not fair but sometimes there
is a slight price that you pay for
choosing to have that debt-free
lifestyle yeah I'll give you another
example and this one still ranks reeks
ranks among the things that reeks but
you know
um
so if you have no if you have no credit
score you're going to pay in a lot of
cases a higher premium on your car and
homeowners insurance you know why
because these Goobs did a little bitty
tiny study in Philadelphia or in
Pennsylvania University of Pennsylvania
about 20 years ago that showed that
people that had no that had bad credit
had a higher claims rate on their
insurance in the event of a wreck or in
the event of a they had a higher claims
rate on homeowners and on car insurance
well no kidding
but hello how about Mo you know so I'm
worth several hundred million dollars I
don't have anything but a big old pile
of cash and I'm a higher risk because I
got a low credit score well that's
dumber than crap of course that's stupid
of course I've got a lower claims rate
I've got to carry 5 000 deductibles on
most of my stuff because I can carry
that much and keep my cost of my
insurance down you know it's just but
this
just stupid because they took this
stupid little tiny study and
extrapolated from that now the whole
freaking insurance industry just about
which is a bunch of lemmings all
following each other off a cliff
um they all go and line up and go
everyone that doesn't have a credit
score now has the equivalent of bad
credit and so we're going to charge you
more when in reality people don't have a
credit score probably have money
probably and are going to have lower if
you'd have done a real study a detailed
research and the industry accepted that
but no what it is is freaking insurance
companies with an excuse to charge more
is what it is now did I get through with
my little rant yes I did well when you
said rank what did you say Reiki ranks
among things that wreak I thought you
were going to talk about rental cars
because they want you to pay credit
rental cars they are charging more well
if you use your credit card they say you
have to use a credit card but if you
choose to use a debit card you're more
risky so you end up paying more well you
know why we found this out when we were
we had Dollar rent a car for a long time
Studios back in the day and dollar went
and did a full thing and they agreed for
a while now they all went broke with
when they you know two with the uh fauci
quarantine they all lost everything and
they got they all got the opportunity to
go into bankruptcy right so after
bankruptcy they came out and and the new
guy's running dollar looked up and went
back to the old ways okay so that we had
to not be the dollar studio anymore so
um now or the Pod studio and we're proud
of that the um and that they don't take
credit cards either so um no they
probably do but anyway the uh but dollar
dollar told us the Hertz people told us
on the inside that the their these uh
Organized Crime Guys the steal their
cars and they do it in like thousands of
them and and it's almost always in Vegas
always use debit cards and that it's
kind of like the insurance thing this is
one person that's one little thing and
so they then assume all debit cards
because they're so narrow freaking
minded they don't understand their own
actual data they don't they don't do a
decent analysis on their own data to
realize oh regular country boy with a
credit cards not our debit cards not a
threat yeah hello wow but um now the
goobers yeah that's that's exactly what
it is exactly where it came from was
organized crime using debit cards steel
cars in Vegas and that and that's where
the whole industry pulled the thing from
they used they used again
bad research bad data leads to bad or
bad analysis of good data leads to bad
problems problems crazy it reeks it
ranks
crazy crazy crazy yeah it's not good
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personalities my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Brad and Brittany are with us
hey guys how are you good how's it going
better than we deserve where do y'all
live uh Fishers Indiana which is near
about 20 minutes north of Indianapolis
Indy okay well welcome to Nashville good
to have you yes and how much debt have
you guys paid off
277 thousand dollars
how long did this take about four years
good for you and your range of income
during that time uh started out at 2 30
and then went up to 300 combined plus
bonuses what do you all do for a living
I'm a sales manager for a medical device
company yeah and I um in sales as well
and uh in medical as well okay wow well
you guys are killing it way to go so
what kind of debt was your 277 it was
our mortgage
they're looking at weird people really
weird I love it what's this house worth
uh anywhere between I would say 550 and
600. how much how much in your
retirement accounts uh it's it's getting
close to a million days hey yeah and
they're alone or no no no no no so
you're you guys but so about 500 there
or two yeah a little over 500 okay so
you're a million dollar net worth yes
baby steps millionaire yes
ding ding two wins on the day I like it
absolutely how old are you two I'm 38
[Music]
oh man oh man so did you guys grow up
rich I know we didn't how much did you
inherit not none so this is you just
gutted this out absolutely which is by
the way how most people do it okay way
to go guys yeah I grew up with uh two
hard-working families that instilled
good values and worked very hard their
whole life would give anybody the shirt
off their back but we learned that and
learned that we needed to really uh get
down and and work hard to be able to
accomplish yeah you know the best gift
you can give your kids is teach them
where money comes from absolutely work
absolutely yeah teach them to work yeah
you know send them to the salt mines
early
oh my gosh I'm kidding I'm kidding kids
it's okay you're not joking yeah Dave we
learned it around Paul joke we learned
it really early age Common Sense
principles from our parents and still
them in us as well okay they had common
sense before it was cool absolutely so
yes awesomeness tell us about this four
years ago what happened how long y'all
been married uh this would be 12 years
12 years okay so four years ago you say
the mortgage is going down tell us about
it yeah so I'll tell you two stories
Dave um two quick ones our journey first
started when I was at my previous
organization I was coming home from a
sales training module or a sales
training meeting and uh Mandy Hall who's
actually listening here today
um I was talking to her about paying off
our student loan debt and how long it
was going to take which was between the
both of us was seventy thousand dollars
this was about 15 years ago and she
introduced me to Dave Ramsey and The
Total Money Makeover and I think in four
days we both read the book and then
translation 13 months later we were
Consumer Debt freeze wow that student
debt-free boom that was the do nothing
so then we kind of went ish for a little
while and kind of trying to figure out
where to go not really truly figuring
out four five and six yet and then we
built the house and in October of 2019
we kind of looked at each other and said
why do we still have this like we don't
have any other debt the mortgage yes and
we were on a 30-year fixed at the time
and when covet hit we've refinanced into
a 15 and we just really cranked it out
from there from then on out and really
just started chunking all of our bonuses
on it started six months before coven
six months and then when the quarantine
hits boom your game on game on because
medical device y'all kept working
absolutely you were essential
yeah there was a there's a period of
time we were at home for a little while
but we did get back out there pretty
quickly yeah that's really great I'm
just the fact that you guys are 37 and
38 years old paid for home millionaires
what do you say to that other person
who's your age but they're still deeply
in debt they still you know maybe they
haven't even bought a home yet what
would you say to them
uh so I would say I I have a mentor
um that is at my company and he always
says play The Long ball and I I do feel
that with us we're playing the long ball
um and being patient which is really a
reflective because I it's hard for me to
be patient him not so much so um play
The Long ball and being patient is my
advice because it's easy to get caught
up in the wants especially what I call
the blackout period of two young kids a
house you know you're just you're in the
thick of it and it's hard to I feel like
you can catch your breath yeah I know
that's right yeah all spending is
Justified in the blackout period
absolutely that's not but we act that
way right yeah you're right I like that
that's a good I like that I've never
heard that phrase
so you know and Dave I said like we we
always had a goal of being debt free
completely debt free and and for me like
it wasn't necessarily about the wealth
Journey it was about the freedom to
choose and you said something I saw you
live and I think it was either Carmel or
Fishers Indiana a while back in the
store story that you said was like you
know if you walk into your job and you
got no payments and your boss is a jerk
you can just turn around and walk away
and when he yells at you you can say I
got no payments and I and I walked out
of that that per uh that presentation
and I said I want that ability to make
that choice not autonomy and I love my
job I love my boss so I don't want to I
don't want to quit or do anything but I
love having that ability and that
freedom to make that choice if we need
to you know the weird thing is is when
you can quit a you usually don't want to
and B you you kind of walk different and
so they treat you different absolutely
it's like I don't walk like a victim you
know and it's it's it changes your body
language it does changes everything
you're going to be a whole lot better at
sales now I mean it's going to be
incredible since you got nothing you got
this now it's just a game yeah yep
there's no there's no need it's just a
game it's fun absolutely and uh yeah I
mean I was contacting the president of a
major company uh last week about us
doing a business and they just emailed
back and told me to pound sand and it's
it's just a game it's just a game right
and it's just fun it was fun that
happened at the last commercial break
yeah
whatever you know next right it's
hilarious so very cool feel to be
millionaires at 37. Freedom stress feels
different and that's what it is the
grass does feel different when you pay
your house off and you walk outside bare
feet so your advice is play the long
game if someone says how do you get out
of debt is that the same advice or is
there something set a goal set a goal
and go after it yeah so and and then
also too like I mean we wouldn't have
been able to accomplish this if we
weren't on the same page yeah I mean
we've throughout our entire Journey
Through the student loan crisis that we
had and then you know paying off our
mortgage we hadn't we had a sold the
entire time I'm curious about that
that's a really good point and there you
know most everybody says that
um and it's true
um now you guys you were on the same
page we've read the book both of us 48
Hours 13 months boom we knock it out mic
drop are done with that debt and then we
went ish when you decided to go game on
again were both of you on the same page
still here he ought to come to Jesus
moments with me
because we were so extreme and that was
pre-kids and I was was like I want to be
able to give them experiences they'll be
able to Live While We're getting out
there yes and he's like Brittany no we
can do this let's stay focused and we
still that's why I think we we would
have done it a lot sooner we still what
I would say we took the kids on a trip
it's intentional yeah I mean I mean Dave
we're we got couches in our house that
are 20 years old and she's just itching
to yeah thank you
it's time
it's been years of me asking so
basically you're leaving here to go buy
a new couch
on the way home hey we've got the live
and give bundle for you most of it's
going to be give for you guys your Total
Money Makeover book an extra one a
financial peace membership and of course
the baby steps millionaires book you are
baby social media and are so proud of
you bring the kiddos up let's introduce
them get their ages and do our debt free
screaming what are their names and ages
this is Kate who is eight this is Jake
who is six
you ready way to go you guys all right
277 000 paid off house and everything
that makes some baby steps millionaires
at 37 38 years old did it in four years
making 230 or 300. count it down let's
hear a debt free screen count it down
three three two one
[Applause]
foreign
wow hey those little kids right there
their whole lives are changed I know
that's right their kids lives are
changed that's called that was sound you
heard those little kids screaming that's
the sound of a family tree chain that's
it those people are heroes very cool
good stuff this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture of the day Proverbs 9 10
fear of the Lord is the foundation of
wisdom knowledge of the Holy One results
in good judgment
Ralph Waldo Emerson said the invariable
Mark of wisdom is to see the miraculous
in the common
I like it Linda is in Los Angeles hi
Linda welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you so much for taking my
call how are you better than we deserve
how can we help
okay my question is twofold
first I want one I'm interested in
paying off my mortgage but I'm wondering
if it makes sense to do that if I know
that later on down the line I'm going to
sell the property yes and then the other
part is when I do get ready to sell it
am I going to have a problem because the
property is inside of the living trust
and my husband passed away the loan was
in his name so now the loan is in the
estate of his name but the trust is in
both of our names so will I have a
problem selling it if the deed is not
going to be coming in my name but it's
going to come in his name
the deed will come from the trust
the trust is the owner of the property
and the trustful sign for the deed who
is the trustee on the trust
I am
you're the beneficiary
Jerry I'm
beneficiary since he passed you're all
three yes
okay
um in Most states that can't be but it
could be in California I don't know I'm
not an attorney okay oh but usually you
can't be the trustee and the beneficiary
on a trust it'd be like a conflict of
interest huh yeah usually
typically that doesn't but it but it
could be I'm not I'm not an attorney
okay but either way a trust is an entity
and the trust is the owner of the
property and the trust will transfer the
deed to the buyer and the trustee will
sign the deed
on behalf of the trust
okay and it doesn't matter that the
mortgage has nothing to do with it
oh okay yeah the ownership is in the
deed the warranty deed the mortgage is
just a lien on the property and if the
mortgage is paid off or not paid off it
doesn't matter the mortgage would get
paid off in the event of a sale
obviously or if you have paid it off
earlier which is what I'm going to
recommend you do go ahead and pay it off
okay and then and then you're free to
make decisions because you're not losing
the money when you pay it off you get
the money out when you sell the house
right
yes it's not like the money's
evaporating we're just we're just
investing in into the we don't have any
debt payments anymore and then when you
you know and so you might want to follow
back up with the attorney that did the
living trust
with just a phone call and go hey pull
this file up I'm a little confused uh
exactly who signs the deed am I the
trustee and the beneficiary is that how
this works and ask him
um just for her just to be sure what
you've gotten yourself into there it's
not a big deal though it's not a problem
I mean I had we had a our last residence
uh our current one isn't but our last
one was in a trust
and uh my wife was the trustee
and um I was the beneficiary
meaning she was in control hello that's
what that means okay uh but yeah we sold
that property and she signed the deed it
wasn't a problem
on behalf of the trust but neither one
of us personally were the owner anymore
so you don't own the property anymore
the trust owns the property
crowded okay okay
thank you I'm not an attorney but
everything I told you is just right
double check it with your attorney okay
okay yeah and pay off your house good
question Tom is in Philadelphia hey Tom
what's up
okay gang thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it sure how can we help I'm
not I'm married 14 years to my life we
have two young kids and it has recently
come to my attention that she is very
unhappy in the marriage
she thinks that we have been hyper
focused on retirement and investing for
retirement and we're missing out on
today as we plan for tomorrow
so I can give you a quick breakdown of
our numbers what the portfolio looks
like the main question is do we sell a
two unit rental property that we have
which would for the most part eradicate
all of our debts with the exception of
our mortgage and give us much more
latitude to do the things that she wants
to do that Frankly Speaking I happen to
be in agreement with after sitting down
and talking about it I feel like we're
missing out on too much what is your net
worth
well
let's see
we have
an 800 000 house with a three hundred
and forty thousand dollar mortgage at
2.7 but that's 500k what's the rest of
your net worth
credit
we have thirty thousand dollars in
credit card debt
when you have in Investments Tom
we have
the two unit rental property which is
paid off it's worth what what's it worth
between between 250 and 280. okay all
right we have 500 000 and 401K
we've got 50 000 in a Roth IRA
and we have a second rental property
that we just bought last year which we
still have a mortgage on that for about
180.
what will it bring if you sold it
I'm sorry say that again
about the same about 250 to 280
somewhere in that range uh we also have
25 000 just sitting in in liquid funds
10 in the checking account another 15 in
a you know she's suggesting what do you
make
combined we make 200 000. okay she's um
suggesting
that you clean up uh some of the chaos
and enjoy some of the fruits of your
labor
I mean if we sold if we sold the two
unit uh like I said the other house
you're not making any money on the one
you just bought it's not gonna use cash
flow because you got no equity in it
right well I mean it's just it's a
bigger problem than it is a blessing I
love real estate I don't like that house
with what you owe on it
okay so I'd sell both rentals and I'd
clean up the mess and be debt free and
let you put yourself on a written budget
that you and your wife agree to that
includes enjoyment
that's what I needed to hear yeah yeah
100 dead 100 Dead free 100 debt free no
rentals you make 200 000 a year and you
can put enjoyment in your budget and
still become very wealthy
there's no reason you can't do both
you've got the numbers to do both
right right but the hyper focus is like
she doesn't feel like she's got a vote
in this process and if y'all start doing
a monthly budget whether she has a vote
in that'll help the
marriage discussion too yeah right sorry
you're uh you're a go-getter numbers guy
am I right
you are right yeah and how old are you
I'm 46 she's 40. yeah okay so when I was
in my 20s I was the go-getter numbers
guy and we owned real estate my wife
even knew never even knew about not
because I hid it from her but I didn't
need her opinion
yeah and you know what you know what she
says that's the worst seven years of our
marriage until we until I went broke
because I was stupid and then when we
started working together we have a lot
better marriage and my success rate on
investments went way up because turns
out she's got a good Common Sense yeah I
get a fee it feels like she's kind of
just along for the ride but she needs
your voice to participate she needs a
vote and when she gets a vote and then
she says Hey I want to build wealth and
go on vacation uh your life's getting
ready to be amazing and you can do both
man yeah I'd clean up these little
rentals and clean up usually rental I'm
with you I think you got a good plan Tom
and I love that you love your wife so
much that you love her more than your
plan your old plan and so you're going
to turn away from the hyper thing and
knock it out I like it man you're a good
guy yeah that's good you love your wife
you're willing to abandon your little
pla get your former game plan and
develop a new one to hit her but also
you don't have to completely abandon the
goal of being responsible and of
Building Wealth I think you can do both
absolutely and uh and you'll be amazed
jump on every dollar and start using
every dollar budget and the two of you
doing your budget together
you're gonna love this you really are
it's pretty cool
that puts this hour the Ramsey Show in
the books Austin Ben James Zack and
Andrew are in the booth the booth dudes
doing the show Jade wash all Ramsay
personality good work today we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]